was ist dass sie dümpelt jahre lang in
den europäischen charts in den hinteren
rängen rum und plötzlich geht sie in
deutschland auf 1 lykke li und deshalb
kommt die schwedin mal ganz schnell nach
deutschland zu einer promotion tour und
damit auch zur kriegs und dort zu jemand
neu man das nicht entsprechen ganze doch
das gespräch mit li und ich freue mich
auch und wir freuen uns auf eure fragen
wie immer am besten als video antwort
hochladen ins kommentarfeld klicken
daneben ist ein button da geht das oder
in die kommentare schreiben aber auf
jeden fall den info text lesen und
kreativ sein und dann steht der
erwähnung eurer frage im community video
nichts mehr entgegen also bis dann
klettern